hello everybody and welcome to part 7 of
our TV basics with Python tutorial
series in this video we're going to be
talking about is getting mouse input
information actually when I say Mouse
it's actually not just the mouse it's
any coordinate input so to speak so if
you have a phone and you're touching the
phone this would include that kind of
input so again that's kind of the point
of keavy is that we can have actually
multiple input to a device but anyways
that's what we're gonna cover now is how
to get you know what's where are the
coordinates that are being actually I
don't know input or clicked or I don't
know what you would touched because
that's literally what it's being called
as a touch so I guess that's probably
the best thing to do so we're gonna be
touching stuff okay so now this is where
we left off we had this nice little
application that's cool
we could work with that a little bit
more later in buttons and all that but
for now we're going to again kind of
break this down to a really simple
element so you can see at the most basic
level what's involved in getting a mouse
you know input or a finger input or
whatever so uh we're going to delete
this we don't really actually delete
that I'm gonna just rename it basically
but from kvu Y X dot widget now we're
going to import just widget again we'll
use that for now and now we need a new
class so we're going to say class uh
we're going to call this class touch
touch input and it's just going to
inherit from widget and then we'll do :
and now we're going to define def um on
underscore touch underscore down and
then self just for typical standards
there and then touch ok so then : now
let's just print the touch now this on
touch down is key V code okay so bring
this up and over so here we go input
management okay so if you go to kiva.org
then go to docs guide
and we come down to input management
here you can see these are basically all
of the things that you have at your
disposal on touch down on touch move on
touch up which basically means a release
right so you can hold your mouse key
down and then you can you know let it go
so you've got those or you can you know
touch the screen and stop touching the
screen and so on anyway this on touch
down for example is a kind of like part
of you know TV almost so anyway on touch
down self touch moving over what we're
going to do now is we're just printing
the touch so that's easy enough
instead of having simple TV for return
float layout however we're going to have
it return touch input and that should
really be it as far as adding touch
input is concerned now we should see it
printed out to our console so here is
our TV application here is our console
let's make some clicks okay so as you
can see as we click we get various
elements here for the position okay
and so let's click write right here for
example so if we click right here we get
a couple of things right we get
basically the you wear it so here and
then let's click see this would be zeros
here let's click here okay so I remember
what I was talking about before with
using X&Y and zero is nothingness and
one is fullness so as you can see we
clicked right at the bottom left corner
and pretty close to zero elements then
we click kind of towards the top right
there almost a 1:1 so you get that
information plus you get the actual X&Y
coordinate information so this is a
little more relative so if you're
expecting that you're going to be using
a lot of different sizes and you want
more of the relative because you might
be using a float layout for example this
might be the superior method to use
because position might change and then
you would have to input all kind I don't
know some sort of algorithm to calculate
what are the new dimensions or where
might the new I don't know think that
the person's
possibly clicking B&R we closed a lot of
it is a lot of what goes on in game
development GUI development is where is
the user clicking and are they actually
clicking on something or especially in a
game has there been a collision or have
we actually shot the person or whatever
so it for it to have this is actually
quite nice because it's more of a
relative positioning not an actual hard
static-x and why anyway that's that I'm
actually gonna like well IIM fitting the
other one too so so another thing that
you might want to have is you might want
to have just general Mouse position but
a probably not and and also the reason
why that's not really useful for keavy
is the idea of key v is to be um a you
know all kinds of applications so in
theory 8 with kv to work on a phone you
can't really have a mouse like just
general mouse position on a phone like
the only way you would possibly do that
is by using your phone and like in
touchdown and then move right otherwise
you can't move a mouse so the same thing
is true over here so the only so the
next thing you would really want to
track is after a touchdown where is the
movement and then obviously you would
want to track maybe a touch up movement
so for example let's um let's just close
out of this and so we've got on touch
down now we can do define on underscore
touch underscore move again it's just
self touch polling print touch okay so
basically the same parameters and then I
believe the other one is just touch up
so I was going to go ahead and just add
that one as well on touch up right so
then let's go ahead let's just copy this
because it's basically all the same so
copy paste on touch move now on touch up
and print let's just add here at least
oh okay save and run that real quick
okay so now let me move this down so you
can see it whizzing by and so we're
holding the mouse now and we're moving
around we can see all those elements and
then we release and sure enough we got
our released message so this is where
the mouse was released in the
coordinates and then again the general
relative I don't know trying to think of
a better better word for it but anyway
but yeah so that was where I was raised
in terms of 0 & 1 so I suppose for
relative or normalized maybe I think of
a good word for it anyway so that's how
you get like Mouse events and stuff like
that and so from here we can actually do
quite a few cool stuff and I think my
favorite example has always been the
paint application and because it kind of
shows off the canvas ability of keavy so
keavy has a pretty cool canvas ability
and we can actually draw on the canvas
with our mouse and since we now have
what's required to track when the mouse
is pressed when the mouse moves and
where that mouse moves like literally
every movement is being tracked here
where the mouse moves and then when it's
done moving we have all that so moving
and creating some sort of paint
application or somewhere where we can
actually draw like you know hi okay
should be relatively simple from here
right so anyways that's what we're going
to be moving on to in the next video is
just creating like a simple application
where we can draw stuff to the actual
screen so stay tuned for that if you
guys have any questions or comments on
this video please feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions until next time